I just Bravo the back Chasers tuned in
with bootleg cab podcast man go crazy
come tune in
yo bootleg cat podcast man special guest
is in here
shout out to Bravo the bag Chaser
welcome home thank you thank you man I
had to come [__] with my boy had to sit
down for a sec glad you're out it never
happened yeah man how you feeling man
you good you get out of my whole thing
is how you pass time when you're locked
up bro I know it's different for
everybody uh she's reading books I
already gang bucks shooting dice
um
what's the spread what's your spread
game like my spare game is crazy man
what and like cheesy manwiches you know
you might you know you might uh
sandwiches out of soup and [__] cheesy
manwiches you crush up a tip right put
some boiling water in there some cheesy
chips right
and then it becomes like a sauce and
then you thought you throw the soup in
there like a little Patty so you boil
the chips until it's a sauce no so you
crush up the tips throw some boiling
water in there then it's like a sauce
okay I got you got you and then you
throw in um the soup
like just the the square you know you
don't break it down bam throw it in
there let that [__] cook so the cheese
gets all up in there yeah take it out uh
put some cucumbers some summer sauces
some chicken all up in there fat ass fat
ass Manwich oh
yeah is this something you'll eat now
that you're not incarcerated man hell no
I seen a pack of soup in my cabinet I
was like yeah that's it that should look
disgusting I just know guys like who
will still make up [__] like they're
still in prison and I'm like guys you
guys know you there's real food now yeah
I think that's just bad luck I think if
you eat that [__] out here that you know
yeah because you're kind of putting it
out there yeah I'm straight I love it
man oh yeah yo
um yeah it was crazy because we were
just talking here from North Hollywood
which is [__] where my Studios at yes
sir it's an area in the LA
uh greater metropolitan area that I feel
like a lot of people are familiar with
because a lot of artists record here yes
sir and it's also kind of like
one of the main places if you move to LA
to chase your dreams you get a spot in
NoHo yeah hell yeah everybody be
recording out here you know it's just
popping out here but it's also like it's
like baby Hollywood it is but it's also
like very a very active place like we're
in the valley so people think when they
come here they think like oh West
Hollywood North Hollywood Hollywood they
don't understand like they're totally
separate they're not close like if you
were to go from North Hollywood to
Hollywood if there's traffic it might
take you like 45 minutes you know what
I'm saying and if not it's like 10
minutes yeah so it's yeah it's quick
because you you know you just [__]
hop over but
um yeah what was it like growing up in
North Hollywood well I was growing up
all around the valley but like up until
my later years I was in North Hollywood
but what high school did you go to I
went to Opportunities For Learning okay
San Fernando uh shout out to San
Fernando best Mexican food Jesus and uh
man La got the best Mexican food off top
off the rip I think San Diego is a
little better yeah why because right
next to the board it's closer to me it's
a proximity thing I've never tried it I
you know but I never tried oh yeah
I've been downtown and hit the [__] in
the glass District
where do you go you go to the little
stands or something yeah and then you go
to like Chula Vista is it Chula Vista is
that what it's called
and then also you could just park at the
border
and then walk over and just get that
[__] just get that [__] huh yeah yeah I
don't know that should be crazy out
there I don't know but yeah but like for
you what was it like kind of because the
valley I feel like you know there is
such a um
if you're in L.A everybody knows about
the valley I feel like if you're not
from L.A you know a lot of people will
say the valley but it's it's separate
you know what I'm saying like it's his
own ecosystem its own politics its own
Vibe like what was it like kind of just
coming up in the valley man uh I mean
you know just same old [__] just
you know like uh try not to getting
[__] I was locked up like a lot of
my juvenile you know when I was a when I
was a teenager just [__] you know gang's
a game you know how that should go out
here yeah
it's just all the [__] you see on TV
that's what it is
you do the like La politics ever spill
over to the valley or is it like
separate it's all like at the end of the
day it's all the same politics like if
you know you know like you know right
it's the same politics from LA to the
valley to the [__] AV it's all the
same politics how many times have you
been locked up
uh highlight three four
what is a why is this last time going to
be your last time
because it's a rap like I said going for
myself back then I didn't have to say
going for myself yeah I was just out
there [__] around like
you got a lot to lose man there you go I
got a son now too so that [__] hit there
how's your son he's two oh yeah you got
like a real little dude man I got a
little man yeah I just been I just had
him he walking and [__] he walking and
[__] talking a little bit he's jibbering
and [__] yeah I had um I had him over
the weekend for two days and I haven't
had them like you know yeah so it was
just dope we were vibing it felt good he
he loved the love is there you know so
[__] I got a son I gotta make it home to
my son yeah you gotta make it home to
your kid and you got to make sure that
you have like a a real like you know
you can help build his future you know
what I'm saying like sir you could be
there to kind of like guide him through
[__] you don't want to miss his his
developmental yeah I'm sure you probably
missed his ass while he was locked up
hell yeah well I'll see him sometimes
through the glass right now yeah yeah
she was cool they say counties like a
really like scary place it's the county
you know and then it it it it is you
feel me like if you go up in there and
you don't know what you're doing but
you know I was in there chilling the
whole time I was in there I was GP too I
was with everybody you're in general
population dead homies general
population the whole time it's crazy
because when I got there when I first
got uh busted when I was in the IRC
I'm walking and it's like a young
Mexican cop you know and then he's like
oh [__] like he's like Bravo like he's
like what's up man like whoa I'm always
good you know and then he starts playing
my [__]
on the like on the little speakers when
we're getting buck oh [__] on my son man
I'm done he's playing my [__] he's
playing my new [__] I'm like damn like
you know I look at him like that's
what's up you know I can't really talk
to him and [__] and then so um
so what happened was uh when we was like
in the tank when we was about to move oh
no when we're going to the showers we
all butt ass naked you know they give
you a shower roll we walking he was like
um he's like hey you want to go to
general population want to walk the main
line or you want to come with us and I
was like I'm gping the whole way he's
like all right thing you know
these flies is crazy right this fly's
like gonna [__] be the death the [__]
is happening bro yeah you're here crazy
so you
first of all I would have been like I
would go with y'all
I'ma just go kick it with y'all where we
going little [__] yeah so for you like
is it because I can only imagine like
being somebody who's famous in La uh
being someone who's famous in hip-hop
period like
is it is it harder do you have a harder
experience in jail like do people like
have to like do you feel like people
[__] with you more man not not hell no
it was like people people was like oh
they see me and they didn't want to come
up to me and said I thought I was gonna
be like weird or stuck up or Hollywood
and [__] right and um
and then yeah I was getting hate too
don't get it [__] up you know it was
love and hate like I'd have people come
up to me like what the [__] yeah what
you doing here like you know I'm like
it's time [__] I'm sitting it down you
know and I became cool with a lot of
people I met a lot of real [__] I
haven't seen some of my homies was
fighting life and they've been fighting
that [__] for years and I was like damn
I was never gonna run into you when I
ran into you here we eating together
right family and so um yeah it was weird
but at the end of the day like I had I
was solid I had my solid group of people
everywhere I went and uh yeah bro how
did these flies turn into two flies
dog
[__] bro I like I swear to God
this shit's like annoying just for for
everybody watching on camera there's
some fly [__] going on in here for real
besides his cookie sweatsuit all right
it's a big burn man I need to roast it
um so like like let me get this straight
so you're you're in a
um going to jail you turn yourself in
right sorry
um
for you are you on probation are you
able to move around freely like what's
your status right now uh parole I had to
go up there to um I got to go upstate
and catch a number of parole number so
so you had to go you were to go to
Delano's prison to reception I hungry
there like two three months yeah up
north is like like uh yeah man it was
Delano it was it was like three hours
away okay okay crazy [__] right
I put on everything I remember the day I
left uh to Delano in the in the in the
bus when we all got chained up
caught the chain it was March 29th
you'll never guess who was on that bus
from who uh Eric Holder [__] that kill
nip I swear to God oh everything I love
he was he was right there on the same
bus and it's crazy because
I'm saying that I'm with a few homies
I'm with a homie from 60s too and then
so I'm like um but he's in a cage though
he's like he was pc'd up so he was in
the cage but he was in the in the last
cage and I and I'm sitting right here so
like his cage is right here and then I
see him I see him just look back on
everything I love and I'm like what the
[__] I'm high too I'm faded so
I'm like what the [__] and I tell the
homie I'm like hey I'm like bro I I
think that's old boy he's like and he
look at me like kind of disrespectful
like man you tripping you hot [__] like
you off drugs like you feel me and then
I was just like all right man bam I go
bang on his on his window boom boom boom
he looks back everybody on the bus like
what the [__] I swear to God and then
he's like you Eric you Eric Holder he's
like yeah this [__] went crazy or
anything else he got pissed on and
Samosa it spit on they were pissing and
spitting on him in the bus man said hell
yeah squirting piss on his ass somebody
like him like can't beat like he has to
not be in general population because as
soon as we got to Delano so look [__]
bus was going crazy [__] shaking
everybody up boom boom as soon as they
found out it was him and then
um they stopped the bus over on the
freeway I mean y'all better chill out or
else we couldn't take ours back to the
county have to catch the whole chain
again so as soon as we got to Delano man
I'll tell you he covered in pissed I
don't know everything I left covered in
pissed they take him out first they take
him out and um they put them away like
you know and then uh yeah he for show PC
left though yeah I feel like there's
just like certain people like I feel
like you've been on a PC yard though
he's [__] you know like people love me
I'm saying like you don't even got to be
like Affiliated you just like yo you
[__] what you did was [__] bro yeah
even the homies Mexicans we tripping on
that [__] Mexicans love that bro family
100 do you have did you have a
relationship with it no I didn't sadly
yeah I feel like I was I wasn't even
popping like that before you know that
happened yes that he's definitely like
my biggest inspiration I'll tell you is
he like like in terms of like his
independency and uh because you're
independent for real for real a lot of
people fake independent you're
independent fake independent yes sir
I'll be doing it so it was really
through him like I swear I watched his
interviews you know like all that gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our good Folks at blue tube
baby that's right shout out to Bluetooth
man listen everyone's always asking me
does Bluetooth work of course it works
because it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
it is Dick season out here bruh you know
what I'm saying you got to make sure
that dick is up to par you know you get
on that blue shoe and uh you're gonna
never like I mean I'm gonna be honest
like
you remember when Barry Bonds hit 70
home runs in a season and now they're
not letting him in the Hall of Fame
like you get off that Bluetooth they're
not gonna let you in the dick Hall of
Fame because it's cheating to be honest
you know what I'm saying so
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up now this is what's dope
about Bluetooth because you want to know
if it works well they're gonna send you
a month for free
free Bluetooth in discreet packaging
delivered right to your door but you
have to use the promo code bootleg
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
everything's online no doctor's office
visits no worrying about [__] having
a weird conversation with some [__]
about your [__] [__] no you
[__] bluetooth.com free month online
you don't even have to leave your
[__] apartment you don't have to
leave anywhere you just order it it
comes in the mail and then you know you
you just you know you get to work you
get to work all right so use that promo
code bootleg and get a free month of
blue chew also want to give a big shout
out to our good Folks at Odd Socks now
this is what's up about Odd Socks I'm
about to reach into my Odd Socks bag
look Odd Socks they got
all of the [__] sick licenses
recently they locked down Coca-Cola
recently they locked down [__]
Transformers Sabin Power Rangers we got
Yoo-hoo we got Sour Patch Kids
you know they got their Odd Socks Basics
and I'm telling you the most comfortable
socks in the world in the [__] world
all right and they can all be yours 20
off
20 off using the promo code bootleg if
you go to
oddsoxofficial.com the most comfortable
socks in the world
and they got draws and these draws are
amazing
these are this is this is a small just
so we're clear this is a small yeah
yeah chicks can wear these you know a
lot of chicks like wearing these booty
shorts around the crib and [__]
oddsoxofficial.com whatever you're into
they got the license WWE Scarface
[__] Breaking Bad whatever
autosofficial.com promo code bootleg go
over there get 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview a lot of
people say that they're like you know
like the music is one thing it was
incredible but like you also could just
like listen to him speak and get so much
gain so much information and like
career
yeah yeah and all that man what's your
favorite what's your favorite uh like
nip [__] like like a song or an album
obviously Victory lapse is only real
album you had a bunch of mixtapes yeah
right true story that's true story [__]
hard yeah
um the TMC the marathon all the original
[__] that's that's the you know how
should I be slapping
um yo so while you're in uh incarcerated
you obviously have money signed suede on
the project that just dropped rest in
peace to him man rest in peace man I'll
let my boy swag for real real sad
situation that happened to him um did
you guys see each other in in jail at
all uh we're in the same place with
different floors so but I heard he was
there I was trying to send a kite to him
and yeah you know but you know so you'll
be moving around and he had caught the
chain before me he had one up Upstate
before me so I was like [__] it I'm
[__] around see him in reception or
something but I haven't run into him but
uh yeah that's it that's it that [__]
crazy sad situation man like for you
like hearing about that in jail like I'm
sure it's it's it's got to be tough
right hell yeah that [__] was crazy I'm
like man I heard about that [__] right
I was on the toilet right somebody come
and tell me they're like oh you know I'm
like man that's some [__] yeah
that's some [__] you're like oh no
I'm like bro like I'm getting mad
because you know I hear rumors about
rappers
just a rumor yeah I get on the phone I
call I call my boy and he first thing he
says it's like bro I was like I just
knew he said bro I was like damn yeah
she was [__] up I was like what you
mean like he alive though like no I was
like man that [__] that [__] if it
didn't feel real to me because you found
me was in the studio like a week before
we both turned ourselves in because he
turned himself in like a week or two
before me so we were in the studio
right there chilling chopping like he
was just telling me he had a lot on his
mind too he was just like you know
telling me [__] who's making music
I'll probably see you in there you know
yeah bam that's what it was the last
time I seen him she was sad man it's
crazy too because both you guys are like
leaders of like
a whole new generation I feel like of of
Mexican artists coming out of Cali that
um
to me like are making music everybody
can enjoy you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah we're kind of talking earlier like
you know when I was growing up like
there was like Chicano rap which was
cool like shot a little Rob and like Mr
Capone and those guys like they were
like extremely like
right you really had to like
either be extremely [__] tapped in
with Mexican culture or be of like a
certain cough to really appreciate it
because it was Chicano rap you know what
I'm saying so I feel like yourself money
signed suede peso peso free him like or
making records that like if you're just
like you guys are just making dope [__]
and you kind of like the leaders of this
new [__] in La so it's dope to see like
you get out have your head on straight
you know what I'm saying like sad man
about suede though for sure yeah that
was another one like me and you were
talking like I mean dming but him and I
bro we were talking like for like a year
straight we just never made the
interview happen bro and I was like damn
bro and then he ended up getting locked
up and
yeah it's a sad situation man I'm sure
he's got a lot of uh I mean I hope he's
got a lot of unreal [__] that he does I
know he does hell yeah that'll help you
know
we got a gang [__] yeah yeah you guys
gotta get a bunch on really [__] yeah we
got some [__] yeah yeah classic [__] too
you just keep those right you know yeah
probably just keep them I mean or just
work it out with his family because why
not bro you know he's got he's got
he's got one kid I think right I think I
seen
yeah I think he's got a baby yeah I've
seen that I don't know I mean you know
[__] that [__] goes towards his family
you know what I'm saying like I'm sure
he would want his family to eat off that
uh hell yeah for sure
um
for you man like how do you feel about
uh
where
because the perception of
being a Mexican in hip-hop I think is
starting to become more like you're an
artist who I look I look at you like
you're an artist who just happens to be
Mexican you know what I'm saying yeah
like
yeah you know what I'm saying but I'm
saying like for you do you feel that
that that like stigma going away where
it's like you know I feel like oh
Jeezy's help with that I feel like that
Mexican OT is helping with that you're
you're doing your thing with that but
like do you feel like you know now it's
like not as much of like
um an uphill battle to get people to
like respect you
hell no I feel like
look sometimes I feel like it's good but
then sometimes I feel like they do try
to boxes in but I mean I feel like we
just artists at the end of the day
that's it our skin color brown you know
like we're like an artist who just
happens to be like the music is dope
yeah hell yeah but I mean I feel like
we're doing our [__] I feel like they
gonna they gotta you know I mean we
going crazy like we're going down we're
doing some like bigger numbers than some
artists who it's just we just we rapping
hip-hop you know 100 I feel like it
shouldn't be uh we shouldn't be our own
category I agree I don't think we are
either I don't think we are either like
I don't think we are yeah no I think
that I don't think so but I think that
like there are still people who are like
oh yeah yeah like he's a dope Mexican
rapper and it's like well he's also just
a dope rapper
yeah he's just a rapper who's dope and
oh he's Mexican yeah yeah yeah like
Cypress Hill back but they were just
hard like you'd be like yo that's
Cypress Hill dog the [__] are
hard like yeah it was hard you know what
I'm saying oh yeah uh who give me um
like you you obviously say you were
inspired by nip a lot but like when you
were growing up like what music were you
listening to what kind of helped form
your uh your style man
um uh nip for sure a gang net like uh
let me see who was I listening to or
that
um
man I can't even think off the top of my
[__] you feel me I listen to 50 too
you got the Melodies yeah 50 was hard
who else I'm trying to think
it was more but you know I just came out
the top of my head for sure I saw you uh
you got Greedo on the album shots of
Greedo he just came through a couple
months ago oh yeah man you're doing good
he got that [__] he got the
[__] rich guy teeth now you
know what I'm saying he got them pearly
whites hell yeah you know I had to get
those too
where'd you go to get your teeth uh I
went to uh right here in Studio City oh
you did it out here yeah Dr uh Trevor
Trevor you know somebody everybody [__]
they hop on the plane and they'll go to
like uh Colombia Mexico pay two five
racks and they come back looking like
big ass fake ass you know white ass
teeth I'm like oh like you don't even
you didn't even try to make them look
real yeah I'd be seeing that [__] too
[__] look like Jim Carrey The
Mask yeah yeah them teeth bro yeah uh
how how obviously the new Project's out
uh how much like music do you plan on
dropping throughout the rest of the year
are you keeping the pressure on them or
like what are you doing
yeah for sure I got I got hella [__] we
got projects lined up
videos are coming a whole lot of [__]
I'm just ready to you know go I'm ready
to go crazy yeah you know have you
tapped in with Bern it all who burner
burner I haven't I haven't I haven't had
a family you gotta make that happen bro
we gotta make that [__] happen ASAP I
[__] with him too burner's a [__]
real life almost billionaire right now
yeah man he he a legend he's on the
cover of Forbes that's hard right trying
to get on the cover of force I we got to
stop the interview real quick tell you
about our folks at my bookie our
partners at mybookie man listen football
season is approaching it is preseason
right now I can feel it just have my
first Fantasy Draft it's time to get
this [__] money NFL is here go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up for a new
account use the promo code bootleg right
now when you sign up they're gonna give
you that first deposit bonus now my book
is crazy because no matter where you're
at you can go on and get in on some of
that NFL action you can get on some of
that baseball action you can get in on
their Live casino
Blackjack roulette slots whatever you're
into it's going down mybookie.ag all
right sign up right now with that promo
code bootleg they're gonna hook you up
real nice first deposit bonus free money
to gamble with bro when you sign up what
are we talking about football season is
here this is literally my favorite time
of the year as a degenerate we must
participate we got to get a little
action in every Sunday on something
maybe a little Thursday night football
action maybe a little pre-season action
who do you think's gonna win the Super
Bowl throw 100 on it [__] it sign up
mybookie.edu use that promo code bootleg
and they're gonna get you hooked up with
that first deposit bonus also want to
give a big shout out to our family at
kingpong man want to give a shout out to
King Palm they have the um sugar Sean
first of all congratulations to Phoenix
Arizona's own sugar Sean for just
winning that title with UFC they did a
collab with them
uh these are the sugar punch honey
orange pre-rolls which are gas all right
now this was dope about King Palm 100
organic all right we're talking about no
tobacco organic leaves and what's dope
is they have these terpene infused tips
that people just love bro they're called
the flavor tips right you like uh you
bust one of these boys out you know I'm
saying you fill it with your stuff
whatever you want to smoke some of that
flour that you got from Jardine
and then you hit the tip
and man oh I just tasted it right now
just flavor full of Flavor now go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg and you're gonna get half off
whatever's on kpop.com if you don't know
King Palm is everywhere go to your local
smoke shop go to your local 7-Eleven
they got King Palms everywhere so many
flavors
so many Vibes the grapes are gas
yo kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg 50 off let's get back to the
interview yo do you get like like you
were you were only locked up for like
what seven months yeah
what is like the craziest thing once you
get out that changes in a seven month
period because the world is kind of like
not the same every three months like
[__] happens there's drama there's like
inventions there's all kinds was there
anything that like was just like you got
out and you're like oh this [__] is
different now like
anything I mean yeah the suede [__] that
[__] [__] me up that [__] don't feel
real to me still
um let me see like
uh the music [__] too like I'm seeing D
baby go crazy that [__] is going crazy
yeah shout out D baby uh that [__] that
[__] I'm like damn you know that's
what's up I'm like what the [__] yeah
he's going on you know just seeing dope
[__] like that
um
that's about it other than that shit's
really the same yeah you know but just
seeing like certain people go up or like
like you know some people not here with
us no more and uh [__] like that or like
the podcast too like seeing your [__]
I'm like damn you going crazy like you
know like you know
are you guys able to watch YouTuber [__]
in jail or hell no hell no I always
wonder like not in the county not in the
county it's harder to get [__] in the
county yeah because it's actual like
shares right there like you know it's
not CEOs yeah it's like police officers
yeah that makes sense so like now you're
you're a cop right yeah you're a cop an
actual cop you're not gonna give us no
phone action yeah man I'd be like bro
I'm like everything I love I'd be like I
send you a thousand dollar cash app let
me use your phone for like 30 minutes
like no what I swear thousand bucks here
you go cash out real quick man damn good
but now yeah yeah take it for the whole
day do you get do you get like uh like
I'm about to say how do you like do you
guys get [__] any sort of like tablet
or any porn
can't you get in trouble if you have
porn
sometimes you you know this
[__] coming back from upstate
and they got some [__] on them you feel
me and they'll sell it like yo give me
five soups for that wait they're selling
pornos not
um
give me five suits for that all right
give me 10 soups and [__] like putting
[__] on their bunks like I got all the
[__] right here you feel me I got it
all in here yes sir I got the spank bang
going sometimes that [__] ain't enough I
feel you that's real sometimes it ain't
enough it's hard you need to you need
that visual man all right everything
wrong I ain't gonna lie though as soon
as I got out some [__] you were
smacking I was right I was hearing [__]
in my paper suit I still have my paper
suit on anything I love right as soon as
you got out as soon as I got out did you
already have it lined up like you knew
who you were like okay I know who I'm
taking down right away yeah it was my
girl and [__] so are you in a
relationship yeah oh shots your girl the
way you said it was like I was running
it up yeah
were you with your girl before you got
locked up uh yeah okay so she yeah I
mean it had to be tough to like you know
and she say solid all put up visiting me
put money on my bucks was she like
moaning on the phone and [__] man I'm
not I wasn't having to do all that but
[__] I was saying freaky [__] on the
phone yeah like I'm gonna get out and
I'm gonna [__] that [__] up I'm gonna do
some things yeah hey [__] you gotta do
what you gotta do man I will be some
[__] though right there just whacking
my [__] at night then homies like we
can't do that while on the phone yeah we
can't do that [__] wait wait wait wait
because because for people like listen
correct me if I'm wrong but when you're
on the phone everyone's next to each
other right uh sometimes you know
sometimes like like it depends where you
at it'll be like one phone or two in the
back until yeah it's like three a.m 4
a.m [__] I have a blanket on them just
beating his dick
what do you do with the
I don't know
we gotta do what you gotta do now the
new album is out man
um a little tape out it's a Tape Project
whatever we're calling it these days
yeah bounce right back super dope
artwork too thank you thank you um new
album on the way yes sir a whole bunch
of [__] listen bro you're really
independent so you really can just do
whatever you want so I'm sure you're
just gonna flood the market as you
should drop [__] about to go crazy is
there anybody who you're a fan of um
that's uh hold on
you got it no
he's trying to get the fly God damn it
anyway I was gonna say is there anybody
who you're a fan of that's only come up
in La that's like that you're just like
I paid attention to oh yeah man I mean
[__] like I've been [__] with uh he
ain't busy you know you're going crazy
right now yeah he's dope he's from the
I.E but he you know he's going done no
he's hard
um he's supposed to be on my shoulder
actually yeah I eat like you know J.I
bands too giant man's as hard as [__]
you know he also putting on throw me my
hat that I try to throw at a fly
yeah J.I Bears
um
well that's about it man just waiting on
a little peso to come home we about to
go crazy what's the latest with him uh
[__] he's good I mean he should be
coming home soon I don't want to spoil
nothing but you know
I'll be talking to him yo I gotta ask
like when you when you get out of jail
like
were you hip to like like so Swifty blue
came on my show and we had like an
interview that kind of went viral not
for the best reasons but it kind of
turned into like I think it turned into
his like villain run which is happening
right now
where he's got these certificates where
you have to check in yeah yeah it's the
best marketing [__] I've ever seen have
you seen any of this [__] I saw the
check-in video all right you know it's
so smart because like he's just like
leading into it and like you could go to
a website and it looks like like a LA
County website and you have to check in
and you could print your certificate I
said it's crazy now I ain't seen that
shit's hilarious shout out to Swifty man
um all right well look man go get the
new uh EP run it up you got merch
hell yeah we got I got a game I got
boxes at the house I gotta get the
Shopify up though hell yeah oh Tour on
the way tour going crazy man tour I'm
about to be everywhere really yes sir
headlining head man how many dates you
know uh I don't know how many we got
so far 10 are we still adding we we
adding we getting in line you gotta open
her yet uh not yet but I'm for sure
bring people with us you know yeah man
hey man go on that road man you gotta go
touch the fans bruh yes sir go touch
them no literally no yeah not literally
yeah literally you're a lady all right
yeah yeah be respectful ladies out there
if you're a fan yeah you know status DMS
you probably get some crazy [__] I don't
know I don't even be checking them like
that to be honest really yeah
bro my DMs be [__] crazy dog yeah
just people offering me money for
interviews all [__] day and I'm just
like I don't do that sorry yeah I'll be
seeing all type of crazy [__] there too
well look man I appreciate you pulling
up we're about to have to do a freestyle
too so y'all can check that out man hell
yeah Bravo the bag Chaser go get the new
project it just dropped uh get that dope
features on there greedo's on there
sways on there who else on there
um a DB about a bag shout out to him I
made in Tokyo on there yeah 24 hours 24
hours on there yeah yeah there it is man
Bravo yes sir fire hey what up man uh
you just watched another episode of the
bootleg cat podcast brought to you by
hard Dean baby shout out to the family
at hardean don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bartenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Hardin in Las Vegas
the number one dispensary in the world
all right and we are so proud to be
partners with them so shout out to
hardeen go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine